dernière caresse et dernier au revoir
pour lieu-dit fans la plus récente
victime du cancer à zhuzhou il y a trois
ans les médecins de l'homme de 62 ans
lui ont annoncé qu'il avait une tumeur
maligne au poumon ses deux filles sont
convaincus qu'une usine de métallurgie à
un jet de pierre de la maison familiale
est la grande responsable de son état de
santé
ça ne peut être que la faute de la
métallurgie dit elle mon père s'est
empoisonné comme bien d'autres de nous
voisins en fête dans le village de
zhuzhou une personne sur dix souffrent
ou est décédé du cancer ici presque
toutes les familles sont touchées à
l'origine de cette catastrophe la
pollution de l'air mais surtout la
contamination de l'eau
l'industrie métallurgique chinoises
rejettent chaque année des tonnes de
zinc et de plomb dans l'environnement
bien qu'il ne soit pas en mesure de le
prouver les résidents de zhuzhou coin
cuisine locale déversent des quantités
astronomiques de métaux lourds dans un
ruisseau situé à proximité ce qui
expliquerait la couleur de l'eau et
possiblement les dizaines de cas de
cancer dans le village une municipalité
qui n'est pas unique en chine
450 endroit porte désormais le sinistre
noms de villages du cancer dans le pays
au banc des accusés toujours les mêmes
responsables des entreprises qui rejette
impunément des matières toxiques dans
l'environnement sans que le gouvernement
ne sévissent
les dernières évaluations montrent
d'ailleurs que les trois quarts des lacs
et rivières sont contaminés en chine
seul le tibet le china iron ore semble
être épargné
cette chimiste évalue la qualité de
l'eau dans le pays elle admet ne pas
avoir bu l'eau du robinet depuis 25 ans
c'est
le principal problème est que
l'information n'est pas transmise de
façon transparente à la population un
secteur personne ne connaît vraiment les
dangers qu'ils encourent en buvant l'eau
de la ville
les deux filles de lieux où elles savent
maintenant que leur santé est en danger
mais sont prises au piège distel comme
plusieurs autres résidents elles se sont
endettés pour payer les médicaments de
leur père
résultat la famille n'a plus les moyens
de déménager même si tout le monde sait
que chaque jour ici hypothèque un peu
plus sa vie ici van kote radio canada
zhuzhou